deutschland will die Ukraine weiter
wirtschaftlich humanitär und auch
militärisch unterstützen Taurus
Marschflugkörper um die die Ukraine seit
vier Monaten bittet gab es aber auch
heute nicht weil noch Fragen geklärt
werden müssen so die deutsche
Außenministerin und damit einen schönen
guten Abend Anna-Lena baerbock nach Kiew
schönen guten Abend welche Fragen müssen
denn noch geklärt werden
Marschflugkörper das sind
Flugkörper mit sehr großer Reichweite
die sind dringend nötig das habe ich
hier auch noch mal wieder deutlich
beschrieben bekommen um den riesigen
minengürtel den das russische Regime
gelegt hat um den Osten der Ukraine
komplett abzuschirmen wo sah seit
anderthalb Jahren keine humanitäre Hilfe
reinkommt um die Menschen dort hinterher
zu befreien das sind hoch moderne
Waffensysteme und deswegen muss da jede
Einzelheit Stimmen und da sind wir
gerade mit Hochdruck dran aber die Frage
war ja was wollen Sie denn noch für
Antworten quasi von der Ukraine in Bezug
auf diese Taurus Marschflugkörper hören
der Kanzler zögert weil er sagt er oder
sein Argument ist ja die Reichweite es
könnte bis nach Russland gehen es ist
aber ja auch so dass man diese
Reichweite begrenzen kann man kann sie
ja programmieren wieso machen sie das
nicht
das stimmt die Fragen haben sich ja auch
die Briten und auch die Franzosen
gestellt unsere Systeme sind technisch
nochmal anders und wie bei unseren
anderen Lieferungen bei ihres Tee zum
Beispiel den Luftverteidigungssystem was
auch eins der hochmodernsten auf dieser
Welt ist wo wir dann aber gesehen haben
wie hoch effizient es ist aber natürlich
nicht wirken kann wenn man dafür nicht
ausreichend Munition hat mussten alle
Fragen geklärt sein und wie bei den
anderen Lieferungen die jetzt so
wahnsinnig große Hilfe leisten ihres Tee
auch den Patriot ist es für uns wichtig
dass wir Dinge nicht nur versprechen
sondern dass wir dann auch wirklich
liefern können und wie gesagt da sind
wir gerade mittendrin das heißt es geht
tatsächlich immer noch um die Reichweite
sie haben die Briten und die Franzosen
gerade angesprochen die haben so eine
Begrenzung wohl eingebaut und Verträge
mit der Ukraine geschlossen und das Land
hält sich auch daran haben sie kein
Vertrauen
doch natürlich haben wir vertrauen der
sonst würden wir die Ukraine ja nicht
seit anderthalb Jahren bei ihrem Recht
auf Selbstverteidigung unterstützen
angesichts der Brutalität dieses Krieges
ist es aus meiner Sicht nur wichtig dass
man Dinge da nicht zu versempliziert
dass man Dinge über einen Kamm schert
die nicht über einen kam geschoren
werden können das Taurus System ist eben
noch mal ein anderes System als die
anderen Systeme und deswegen habe ich
eben deutlich gemacht dass es für uns
wichtig ist alle Dinge ausreichend zu
klären ihr werdet es sowieso machen hat
heute ihr Amtskollege Kollege gesagt
würden Sie denn wenn sie könnten jetzt
liefern oder stehen sie da dieses Mal
wirklich an der Seite von Olaf Scholz
der ja immer etwas länger braucht bis er
dann tatsächlich liefert
ich verstehe dass die Frage in
unterschiedlicher Richtung gestellt wird
aber ich habe dazu alles gesagt und vor
allen Dingen ist mir wichtig dass wir
eben nicht nur die Frage von der
Verteidigung sehen ich war ja heute hier
auch um den eu-prozess mit zu
unterstützen der so wahnsinnig wichtig
ist für die Zukunft der Ukraine und auch
die Frage wie wir Menschen in den
besetzten Gebieten die wir ja unter
anderem mit diesem Material hoffentlich
endlich irgendwann befreien können wie
wir die erreichen können mit humanitärer
Hilfe wie gesagt seit anderthalb Jahren
hat die Menschen in der Ostukraine kein
Hilfskonvoi erreicht seit anderthalb
Jahren sind Menschen dort gefangen
gehalten ich habe gerade
Familienangehörige getroffen meine
20-Jährige die gesagt hat mein Vater
wurde verschleppt vor zwei Jahren die
letzten zwei Geburtstage konnte er nicht
mit mir feiern sie trug sein Sakko
als glauben daran dass er irgendwann mal
wiederkommen wird und darum geht es eben
auch und deswegen stellen wir uns in
schwierigen militärischen Fragen aber
deswegen hören wir nicht auf auch alles
diplomatische alles humanitäre dafür zu
tun dass die vielen Tausenden von
Menschen seitdem wir seit so langer Zeit
nicht wissen was mit ihnen eigentlich
passiert hoffentlich irgendwann erreicht
werden können EU-Beitritt auch wichtig
für die Ukraine Energieversorgung auch
das war eines ihrer Themen auch wichtig
aber sie wissen dass man damit natürlich
und das scheint ja dann doch immer noch
auch das Ziel Deutschlands oder aber
auch der Europäischen Union zu sein den
Krieg zu gewinnen dafür braucht es
Waffen was bringt denn so eine Reise wie
heute außer einem etwas bei der
Pressekonferenz ungehaltenen
ukrainischen Außenminister und einer
vielleicht an der ein oder anderen
Stelle etwas genervten deutschen
Außenministerin
klar demonstrativ gezeigt die
Solidarität die sich dann auf Fotos
wieder spiegelt aber was noch
also man sollte Pressekonferenzen nicht
als Maßstab für die Zusammenarbeit sehen
gerade weil wir uns seit diesen
anderthalb Jahren so gut kennen ist es
wichtig auch für die Ukraine und ich
treffe hier so viele Menschen an einem
Tag die sagen wie wichtig ist für sie
ist dass wir hier sind dass sich das
Umspannwerk sehe was letzten Winter so
hart getroffen worden ist wo es Blackout
hier mitten in der Hauptstadt gibt wo
ich mit daran wirken kann dass eben vor
dem Winter dieses Umstand wann Werk so
geschützt wird dass nicht wieder bewusst
Strom Verteilzentren angegriffen werden
in der Hoffnung damit die
Wasserversorgung die Wärmeversorgung zu
zerstören ich bin hier um weitere
Unterstützung auf den Weg zu bringen bei
der Energieversorgung wie wir z.B das
ukrainische
Elektrizitätsnetz noch besser anders
europäische ankoppeln können und bei der
Frage wie wir die Menschen in der
Ostukraine über das Internationale
Komitee des Roten Kreuzes erreichen
können
zum Militär dürfen wir nicht vergessen
es geht jeden Tag um das er überleben
von Millionen von Menschen in diesem
Land und erst recht jetzt wenn wir
wieder vor einem Herbst und vor einem
bitterkalten Winter stehen sagt
Anna-Lena bärburg die heute in die
Ukraine gereist ist um unter anderem den
Außenminister aber auch den Präsidenten
zu treffen vielen Dank fürs Gespräch
danke ebenso alles Gute